what did you mean when you said that an
actor approaching a comedic scene can't
for one second think what they're doing
is funny if you're doing a sketch like
if you're doing Saturday Night Live part
of the fun from the audience perspective
is they're having fun knowing you're
having fun and so you're kind of in on
it we all laugh when someone breaks
character and starts cracking up and
they're trying to look away we get even
more enjoyment out of it and that's
legitimate it's fun it's loose it's life
but if you're doing film or television
show that's carefully scripted if the
character realizes something's funny it
takes the onus off the audience to laugh
because they're doing it you're doing it
it's the same thing when a character
easily cries if a character cries easily
the audience doesn't have to but if a
character tries not to cry
that's when the audience will